hi i'm david i'm js and i'm andy and
this is the epic movie review for
mockingjay part one uh we just saw the
movie uh stars jennifer lawrence's
katniss it's the third movie of the
hunger games series and we really love
hunger games and js what did you think
well i got to be honest i was kind of a
fan of the first film i thought catching
fire was a step up and so i was you know
it's going to continue that trend it's
just going to be up from here on out and
i thought the first film was actually
better than the second interesting for
whatever reason i thought the the
overall vibe of the second was it was
just a little too blockbustery for me
like i kind of liked the fact that the
first film
felt like it had a smaller budget and
was kind of like a they really kind of
just made the film and it didn't feel as
manufactured as the second film okay so
i really liked kind of how how natural
and and organic the first film felt
david what was your favorite part of
this one my favorite part is when i want
to say the district 13 soldiers go in to
save peta and so if you like zero dark
30 it's a very zero dark 30s style scene
which you know smoke bombs are being
released and uh repelling is being done
by soldiers and liam hemsworth has been
taken up into sort of the
i guess i would say the soldiers
movement of the uprising and i think
that's really cool and they go in to
save uh peta it's interesting that you
should mention zero dark 30 because i'm
going to reference another war movie and
that's full metal jacket believe it or
not because they are making a propaganda
film for i would say like a good portion
of this movie like that takes up a lot
of their rebellion that's going to be
what ignites this
you know mockingjay revolution not all
that there's that sequence in full metal
jacket where they're making vietnam the
movie and i got a lot of those vibes and
that's that's a good thing it felt to me
by the end of the film like it was kind
of a combination of a lot of different
types of films in that regard it fell a
little short um of my expectations
because it kind of was half baked in a
lot of ways when it when it came to
developing different plot points and
developing different character
relationships but what did you guys
think it did have so many things that it
wanted to tackle and yet this is very
much a part one hence the title and so i
mean it does feel like we're only
getting half of the story another reason
that i prefer this film to the previous
ones is that the caliber of the cast is
just getting better and better each time
i mean this time around we have julianne
moore phyllis sumer hoffman has a more
significant role and i love all those
things so philip seymour hoffman passed
away but he was still able to be in this
movie and at the end there's a very
loving dedication title to his name
which i think was really cool yeah i
thought one of the best scenes was when
katniss was still reluctant to become
the hero
and she is looking out at all this
wreckage and she realizes that obviously
there's this internal um conversation
going on where
she doesn't want to be the hero but
she's confronted with this harsh reality
and i think that she did a really
phenomenal job um kind of making that
transition in the scene where they're
looking at all the wreckage in district
12.
i mean it's common knowledge that
jennifer lawrence is no small fish in
the pond of hollywood right now like
she's a fantastic actress but yet in
this movie katniss is not a good actress
which is really interesting they they
actually have there's some comedic
moments where she's trying to act but
that moment that you just mentioned is
one such scene where she's actually
genuine yeah it goes from forced acting
to like an actual legitimate concern for
the well-being of all the people right
so david what were your overall
impressions of the film it's an
interesting movie if you like war movies
and you like hunger games i think this
is definitely the movie for you
jazz well i still think it actually is
continuing that trend i like this film
more than the previous two i might be
alone on that of us three but yeah i
think it is a solid effort in this
franchise i think it's worth watching um
it was a really interesting film there
were a few moments in the plot and in
the character development where it was
it didn't make a ton of sense but i
thought overall it was an interesting
film filled with good acting um a lot of
big names obviously um if you're a huge
fan of the hunger games franchise i
don't think you'll be disappointed i
think that it delivers what was expected
from it
absolutely so let us know what you
thought of the hunger games mockingjay
part 1 in the comments below so all in
all good movie uh if you're interested
in seeing it which i think you should
you can get your tickets here um for
fandango movie clips i'm andy i'm js i'm
david thanks for watching
you